Dwayne "The Rock" Johnson can kind of do it
all.
Successfully transitioning from a career as
one of the most popular and accomplished wrestling
stars of all time, he's gone on to a Hollywood
career that's spanned everything from action
flicks like the Fast and Furious franchise
to family films like The Tooth Fairy to comedies
like Central Intelligence.
Johnson is a likable guy who always seems
happy to be wherever he is, and he never takes
himself too seriously, particularly on movie
sets.
Here's a look at some bloopers that make us
love The Rock even more.
Walking Tall
Johnson is tough—the kind of guy who could
easily smash things without a need for special
props or stuntmen to do the dirty work for
him.
At least one would think that would be the
case.
When the wrestler was cast in one of his first
major lead roles, as Chris Vaughn, Jr. in
the 2004 remake of the '70s classic Walking
Tall, he discovered that his toughest enemy
wasn't the bad guy at all, but rather a particularly
obstinate car taillight.
"I'm strong, I swear."
Journey 2: The Mysterious Island
A not-so-little-known fact about Dwayne "The
Rock" Johnson: dude is seriously jacked.
His muscles are absurdly large, so on the
set of Journey 2: The Mysterious Island, he
decided to let his body do the talking instead
of his mouth, to hilarious effect.
"What is this place?"
The Game Plan
It's almost like Johnson went full "Method"
actor with this blooper.
In The Game Plan, he plays a star quarterback
who's thrust into the wackiness of fatherhood
upon suddenly learning he has an eight-year-old
daughter.
But it turns out there are certain pitfalls
involved in having a tea party when you're
as massive as The Rock.
"Small chair, big guy.
Classic."
The Other Guys
It looks like Johnson had cold feet when it
came time to film his big scene in the cop
comedy The Other Guys, in which he briefly
co-starred opposite Samuel L. Jackson.
The two extra-awesome detectives end up jumping
off a building.
At least, they're supposed to.
"Ahhhhh!
Whoops."
"I didn't know we were supposed to ---"
Central Intelligence
In this clip, Johnson shows he's not too tough
to take a little ribbing.
After he admits to the character played by
comedian Kevin Hart that his name is made
up, Hart gives him a pep talk, arguing that
having a made-up name isn't such a big deal.
Hart then rattles off a bunch of cool names
that everybody knows aren't real, including
someone very familiar to Johnson.
"You think, uh…
Mr. T, and Sting, and the Rock?
You think those guys are real?
Those are a bunch of dumbass nicknames by
a bunch of dumbass people."
The Tooth Fairy
Well, there's a magazine for everything and
everyone: even tooth fairies.
In this blooper from the set of the family-friendly
comedy The Tooth Fairy, in which Johnson plays
against type as…a tooth fairy, he shows
that he's still a man—a man with needs.
Race to Witch Mountain
Johnson keeps the mood light and shows he's
got some pretty agile improv comedy skills
for a guy best known for big and flashy action
movies.
During the filming of this Disney remake,
Johnson yells out the names of a bunch of
different animals in an attempt to distract
another character, including one very dangerous
animal in particular.
"Is that a woodchuck?
Ferret?
Kangaroo?
Vin Diesel… guy's better lookin."
Fast Five
Speaking of Vin Diesel, here's Johnson messing
around on the set of Fast Five.
He's only pretending to mercilessly pummel
Vin Diesel about the head and face, over and
over again, though according to internet rumor,
he probably wishes he had unloaded for real
when he had the chance.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!